tiger for the first time he's never had
a reason to be scared of like hornets
and bees and there are some in the
backyard
dude some hornet stung that kid twice
that [ __ ] satan's devil's [ __ ]
armies lying
dude just oh man i've never heard him
scream out like oh
dude i don't think that feels good oh
you ever stood by anything like that a
ton
it must have [ __ ] hurt the way he
cried out
i've been stunned by scorpion oh really
in arizona yeah it was in my bed
smaller [ __ ] got me uh it was probably
like this it got me uh
right below my balls and then on my calf
damn yeah
got me twice it hurt like a [ __ ]
the one that woke me up was
the one on my calf i knew as soon as i
like that woke me up it
as soon as it happened i was i was like
i don't know 23. i knew exactly what
yeah my whole leg was just [ __ ] shot
the whole day when was the last time we
got stung by
i'm terrified because a kid i get stung
so many times but you know when you're a
kid you
you make it so dramatic i can't remember
what it's like so i'm terrified of them
yeah terrified never i'm never happy
i've never been stung by anything and
those hornet days are just different
like bees pollinate the world we need
them they make honey
or nates what are they here for you just
kidding
where the bees jump that hornet oh yeah
bro
that shit's insane they [ __ ] them up
they [ __ ] them up because it attacks one
of them which like they
set like they set it up that way is it
like a gang war yeah i guess but one
sacrificed his body
one second and then the rest is [ __ ]
boom
tiger like the whole fam we're
barbecuing all day there's music
everybody's outside i'm like dude you
gotta go back outside he's like no i
need ceo he says i need space i'm not
going out there
you don't need space dude and he's
crying
he goes i'm sick of this cruel world i'm
like
what are you watching dude where you
come up with these
random [ __ ] cruel time challenges
stung by a [ __ ] wasp dude he's
watching tele novella
i know i'm like i gotta get him back out
there so i i go oh hold on dude i'm
gonna go outside let me see what i can
do
so i come back in like dude talk to the
head uh hornet out there
we came to agreement they're not gonna
mess with you anymore he's like really
you talk to him like yeah he's like
they speak english i'm like what dude
you're five just rock and roll
[Applause]
he's like you talk to me i'm like yeah
tiger and then it goes down this deep
hole i'm like dude just get outside for
god's sake i don't speak beef or [ __ ]
get out there i love how kids just like
everything
everything's real how did you talk to
him like what do you mean how did i talk
to me like
do he speaks english i'm like no does he
speak spanish like
no he's [ __ ] speaking he goes you
speak b.o
yeah and he's like oh so what'd you say
to him like i said to him
like leave us alone tiger's not a bad
kid don't sting him anymore and he
agreed to it he's like
[Music]
that's what's funny about kids they ask
questions that you don't literally [ __ ]
no never because you're like oh yeah the
beat yeah it's cool
and then he's like hit you with another
question in my head i was like yeah i'm
just
like
and i had like two whiskeys in me
like we came to the truce he's not gonna
mess with anymore he did go out there
you wouldn't understand dawg yeah he did
go subtitles for that [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] terrifying i remember my
dad that's why i was so scared of bees i
was like
seven and there's a beehive in our shed
where we used to live in aurora
and he's like oh here it i'm sorry it
was a [ __ ] hornet's like
nest so if you know the bee spray
doesn't work on hornets
it doesn't work no they eat that [ __ ]
like it's [ __ ]
you know gatorade it doesn't work on
them my dad didn't know that gives me a
thing it was right spray them i'm gonna
go
over here and get some stuff so i'm like
cool i'm spraying and they're like what
the [ __ ] is this yeah and they all come
out sting me in the neck
the back terrified puffed up huh
terrified
terrified and the the the hornets they
have like that dirt
um yeah right that adobe yeah they feel
like
yeah yeah yeah the whole [ __ ] two
[ __ ] condo yeah made out of dirt is
that it
yeah it's almost like paper right
they're [ __ ] terrifying dude [ __ ]
them things
what are they here for dude i don't know
besides to cause
pain jim find out what are hornets for
do we need hornets
yeah yeah and those black black long
juicy ones with the abs
they look like little helicopters no
that's a june bug no
you never seen that black coronate with
the abs
a little bit of hair on them no oh dude
i'm thinking of jun
help us pollinate oh get the [ __ ] out of
it
[Laughter]
we have no figs no fig newtons okay i
can
deal without fake news
like that though hornets and p pepper
wasps prey on other insects help keep
pests
inspect or whatever man they're here for
population control
yeah all right they're [ __ ] but also
who who [ __ ]
when's the last time you had a fig
newton there's been a while that's a
good question do you like those
[ __ ] yeah one's the last time you have
here though with a nice cup dark roast
coffee a nice fake news
but they have raspberry they have that
weird like uh they have different
flavors now fig but i like the raspberry
yeah the other [ __ ] nice hard pass
really hard
was last time you had one though oh it's
been years yeah